well we've been calculating angular
momentum about a point recall our
definition of angular momentum we've
been looking at cases where the particle
is moving literally now let's look at a
case where the particle is undergoing
circular motion so suppose we have a
particle that's undergoing circular
motion m and let's choose some axes and
our particle we denote that it's
rotating about the vertical axis I'm
going to call that axis K hat and I'll
make that Omega squared Omega Z
positively so it's rotating about the K
axis the z axis now when we calculate
the angular momentum we know because
it's rotating about the z axis this is
our z axis that the particle has a
velocity tangential to the circle so
it's momentum is tangential to the
circle and we draw our vector R s2 where
the object is now what is the you could
solve this in Cartesian coordinates but
then you might have to do some vector
decomposition but because there's a
central point to this motion whenever
there's central point we like to choose
cylindrical coordinates and the way
we'll do that is we'll define some angle
theta if this were my plus X minus y
axis then that's consistent with K hat
being up and our definition of Omega and
I'll define an R hat unit vector which
is pointing radially outward from the
center of the circle and a theta hat
vector which is tangent to the circle
and now I can calculate I can write down
say the radius of the circle is R then L
of s the vector R s has radius R
pointing outward and the momentum vector
is pointing tangential and that's a very
easy cross-product to make our hat cross
theta hat that's what we're defining to
be K huh
maintaining the cyclic order and so we
get R
que hat now for circular motion the
momentum magnitude is M the magnitude of
the theta component we've made that
positive which is M R Omega Z and so LS
is there's an R here and another are
there so we get M R squared times Omega
Z ok huh this is our vector Omega now
this turns out to be the moment inertia
of a point particle located at the
center and so we conclude that the
angular momentum is proportional to the
angular velocity now that's no surprise
in this particular case why because the
vectors are s and P are in the plane of
motion and when you ever you take a
cross product L is perpendicular to both
of those vectors so it's perpendicular
to the plane of motion and therefore L
has to point in the Z direction